do you guys think that sex is a need
that men can't live without I think if
you what do you think would happen if
there wasn't corn I think I think
society would be very violent wouldn't
it I think if you get a lot of men you
say in the animal kingdom isn't it it's
the same sort of thing isn't it you get
you know one alpha male that's got the
females and the others are always
fighting in for position willing to
fight to the death I think you'd get
quite a violent society and that's one
of the reasons why monogamy came about
was to stop that because if you have men
that are not having sex and not getting
that frustration I guess out they're
going to take out on society I think if
you took away corway from men I think
men's mental health would suffer